hello everyone and welcome to another
very exciting game also from the Dos
Hermanas Tournament of 1996 Vladimir Kik
versus vishwanathan Anand and um I I
said in the previous video that kaspar
and Anand both finished half a point
behind of tapalo and kramnik so I
thought we we should best explore a
couple of more games and this one uh it
really features everything and it
features a game style from Kik that you
would not expect um from a modern
kramnik uh but you know likeing the
previous game and liking the game
against kaspar if you haven't seen them
first two links in the description below
really really awesome games uh this one
uh features not only that but also uh
incredibly precise play as it took um uh
over a 100 moves for this game to finish
so let's check it out uh kramnik with
the wi pieces opens with Knight to F3
Anand replies with Pawn to G6 the uh
sort of the fiano variation uh D4 we
have Knight to F6 and now Pawn to C4
transposing into the king's Indian
defense Bishop to G7 uh and now Knight
to C3 we have Pawn to D5 transposing
into the groomfield defense uh C
captures Knight captures and pawn to E4
so this is all very standard stuff even
in those days Knight captures B captures
and now Pawn to C5 in the spirit of the
groomfield even today this is the
considered the strongest move the Rook
is on A1 so of course um makes even more
sense to attack the center uh Rook to B1
we have castles and now bush Bop to E2 C
captures on D4 C captures and queen to
A5 uh sorry Queen to A5 with check uh
Bishop to D2 blocking check and now
Queen captures on A2 and now if you
count to the material uh you can see
that black is up a pawn an is up a pawn
but it's a very well-known line and
white very happily goes into this butth
it looks it just looks very scary I mean
you have the da8 to B Pawn or pawns are
connected uh why would you go into
something like this well uh castles we
have Bishop to G4 and now Bishop to G5
putting pressure on the E7 Pawn but just
Pawn to H6 Anan doesn't care about D7
Pawn because then he gets to play Rook
to E8 and he will also put pressure on
the White Center so here Bishop back to
E3 and now Knight to C6 giving up the B7
Pawn that's not really an issue it's uh
been decided many times that this was
best you know just a continued
development Pawn to D5 and now Knight to
A5 interestingly two years after this
game Gary Kasparov will have this exact
same position against Kik with the black
piece Sonic Kasparov will shift the
Knight over to E5 their game ended in a
draw uh so uh let's see how Anand does
with Knight to A5 and it's a very
natural Square for the knight in the
groomfield uh we have Bishop to C5 now
putting pressure on the E7 Pawn once
again and now Bishop to F6 defending
here uh Pawn to E5 this is a beautiful
move by Kik um getting more control over
the A1 Square so now if you don't take
the pawn just Rook to A1 and your knight
is in trouble so the pawn has to be
captured Bishop captures on E5 but again
uh what was the point if Knight captures
isn't the bishop here just hanging well
the point was Rook to B4 and now Kik
even though he's down two pawns uh look
at this he's threatening the bishop he's
threatening Rook to A4 to go after the
the Knight and the queen what can you do
here well first things first we have to
eliminate one of the attackers Bishop
captur on F3 Bishop captures and now
Rook eight to E8 again uh this has all
been played before nothing new here uh
Bishop to E3 uh if you if you play Rook
to A4 right away it's not as impressive
because uh I best if I just show it if
Rook to A4 Queen to B3 offers a queen
trade Rook captures on A5 wins the
Knight but now you play Queen captures
on D1 and after Rook captures on D1
there's B6 and now you win your piece
back or you go for something like D6
trying to trap The Rook on f8 but then
he captures on D6 and you have to give
up the piece somehow captures captures
let's say Rook to A4 and it is black who
will uh be pushing this for a win as
black is up material so instead after
Rook 88 we have Bishop back to E3 so you
don't have that B6 move with a double
attack at the end of the line H but now
Knight to C4 we have Bishop captures an
H6 going after the rook and Knight to D6
this is the only move of course if you
try Bishop to G6 then you will blunder a
piece with Queen to D4 check then wins
the Knight so instead after Bishop
captures an H6 we have Knight to D6 only
move for Anand uh and now Bishop
captures on f8 the position also has
been reached in 2001 uh Boris gelfan
haded with the white pieces and he
continued with Pawn to H4 here uh
interestingly okay even in 2001 the
engines wasn't weren't really impressive
uh but um yeah the engine says okay Pawn
to H4 is fine but the move uh uh
crowning played is the the strongest
move so okay Bishop captures on f8 and
now there is a game where King captures
on f8 was played but here we have Rook
captures and it is now as of move 22
that this position has never been
reached again uh so let's see how uh how
Kik continues this now you could go for
Rook to A4 and it's a move that pretty
much everyone would go for you attack
the queen and you win the A7 Pawn but he
wants to uh make uh you know the
position count he plays Pawn to H4 and
he wants to go after the black King okay
Rook to C8 now you can't go A5 because
Rook A4 again will attack the queen and
the pawn but B5 uh it is very
interesting now if Pawn to H5 Pawn to G5
and now you continue pushing on the
queen side also something to consider
for Anand here but okay he went Rook to
C8 he wants to get his Rook into the
attack and now Bishop to E4 uh putting
more pressure on Black's King side and
now Queen to E5 you could also eliminate
the the bishop here but that's just uh
uh much better for for Kik as after
Bishop to D6 uh happens then Pawn to H5
and white just breaks through so instead
Queen to A5 was played putting pressure
on the rook and now Rook to A4 attacking
the queen queen B5 uh and now again H5
is very strong but we have Queen uh
Bishop back to
B1 uh trying to get uh uh the attack
going against that G6 pawn and you don't
want Knight captures an E4 happening now
that your Bishop is very strong so here
we have Rook to C5 stronger for Anan
would have been Rook to C4 offering a
rook trade he went for Rook to C5 going
after the D5 Pawn but now Bishop to D3
attacks the queen and once the queen
moves just Rook captures on A7 so
finally vad does go after this Pawn Rook
captures on D5 uh which is possible of
course there is no check to pick up the
Rook due to the G6 push uh and now Rook
to A8 with check also very nice would be
Queen to F3 it's just very very annoying
putting pressure on the position on the
Rook if the Rook moves also on B7 H H5
is coming so Queen to F3 not a bad idea
but he went for Rook to A8 with check
King to G7 and now the immediate Pawn to
H5 okay Rook to D4 The Rook is nicely
protected here and now we have Queen to
E2 just getting uh out of the out of the
Rook here uh Bishop back to F6 and now H
captures on G6 finally the capture
happens and now Bishop back to B1 uh
Queen to G4 uh interestingly both of my
phones started listening to me at the
same time must have been somewhere that
I said uh but okay Queen G4 and now
Queen to A2 now again you could trade
here just uh let's say you trade here
captures captures and you play Pawn to
G3 uh it is possible you you R the
exchange it is white who will be playing
for the win here but Kik doesn't want to
trade Queens he plays Queen to A8 he
wants to go for a mating attack uh okay
Knight to C D4 stopping the queen we
have Queen to B3 putting pressure on B7
and now Pawn to B5 very nicely done by
Anand uh point is that if you play Rook
captures and B5 which seems like
something you should be able to do
Knight D2 and uh White can
resign uh there's no good way to counter
uh Queen to F3 check uh if you go for
for some sort of a Checkmate then Queen
F3 check King has to move and this will
be Checkmate and other moves don't
really help you like if you go Queen to
B7 it just Knight captures an F1 one and
okay you've stopped Knight F3 check but
you're just uh lost here you can't you
can't recapture due to mate on D1 so
really bad position so after B5 Rook to
E1 was played uh and now comes Rook to
D2 again there are some moves uh maybe
you could consider here like Queen H5
followed by Rook to H4 going after the
Rook to H1 Checkmate which will be
countered with something like G3 and
Bishop to E4 to cover the H1 square or
even B4 is very nice here again point
being that if you capture the Knight A3
just wins The Queen Is attacked and also
mate is being threatened so B4 you know
just a nice move to throw in at all
times but okay Rook E1 Rook to D2 was
played by Anand also not just with the
idea of maybe harassing the queen but
going after that F2 Pawn uh will be very
nice maybe bishop to D4 can come next so
here Rook to A2 this is how Kik counters
that Rook to F1 was the other way to do
it and now Rook back to D5 with have
Bishop to E4 now attacking The Rook Rook
to E5 as The Rook on E1 is undefended
Rook a to E2 doubling up and now Queen
to
H4 uh Rook to G5 is the other maybe
potential move but the G2 Pawn is nicely
defended so it's not really that
impressive Queen to H4 was played now
trying to get Rook H5 and maybe Queen to
H1 Checkmate but now Pawn to G3 of
course Queen to H6 and now Queen to D3
we have Knight to D6 now putting
pressure on the B Bishop uh Bishop to D5
and Rook captures on E2 finally we have
Queen captures on E2 and now Queen to H3
so this is the position you have two
pawns for Kik and three pawns for Anand
but Kik is up the exchange he has a rook
for a knight now if Anand can have his
E7 Pawn defended and for example get
this Pawn to B4 which are dark squares
uh and let's say the bishop on D6
controls both of those pawns uh as Kik
has a light Square Bishop he's not
really going to be able to uh attack
those pawns or the bishop so it is
fairly close to a draw but only if you
can get that uh going so Bishop to E6
attacking the queen queen back to h8 and
now Queen to F3 we have Queen to B8 now
preparing to push the pawn uh King to G2
and pawn to B4 now the pawn is very
nicely placed on B4 and while black
would very much enjoy pushing it to B3
and B2 uh of course Kik made sure that
the pawn never reaches the B3 Square as
it is defended twice on on a light
Square so Rook to
H1 uh going maybe after some uh you know
uh Kings at attacking ideas uh you could
also block the pawn with Bishop to B3
but as it's defended there's no rush we
have Queen to B7 offering a queen trade
Bishop to D5 for the moment Kik declines
the queen trade Queen to B5 and now uh
Pawn to G4 uh we have Knight to F7 and
now a bishop back to B3 we have Knight
to H six another way to do it is Knight
to E5 but it's uh again very tricky to
figure out what to do and after Queen A8
going after Queen to h8 you will have
Queen to C6 check and you just trade
Queens here so that's uh one way to do
it but it's not uh I mean it's nothing
uh spectacular for black so Knight to H6
instead was played uh Rook to E1 and now
Queen to
G5 putting pressure on the G4 Pawn Rook
to E4 defending and attacking on B4 and
now kn Knight to F5 of course you cannot
capture the the pawn as Knight to Knight
H4 check would win the White Queen so
Queen back to D1 and now Knight to H4
with check King to H3 and now Queen to
C5 uh so what can you do here the the
pawn is defended the F2 Pawn is also
being threatened Queen to E2 uh just
defending the F2 pawn pawn to G5 now
defending the Knight here and putting
everything on a dark square look at this
all everything is nicely defended uh is
there is there a way for kiik to break
through this he he plays Queen to C4 and
that's why maybe instead of this G5 move
maybe some other moves could have been
considered like maybe throwing in some
checks first but there's no good way to
avoid Queen to C4 so okay G5 was played
we have Queen to C4 and now you kind of
have to trade you can't really allow
Queen to G8 check so captures was played
Rook captures and now Bishop back to
C3 and now this is the position same as
we had before only now the Queens are of
the board and uh still how do you how do
you attack those pawns and dark squares
well the only way that you could do it
is if you maybe got your king a bit more
active let's see if you can get your
king to E6 uh imagine this was the
position this looks much more winnable
than this so that's kind of uh What uh
Vladimir will have to do so Rook to C5
was played going after the pawn Knight
F3 defending we have King to G3
attacking the Knight now Knight to E5
again not allowing the captures uh Rook
to B5 and now Bishop back to D2 guarding
the G5 pawn and the B4
Pawn uh we have Pawn to F3 and now
Bishop back to C3 here uh you should
probably wait with this you as long as
the bishop is on D2 you're not just um
guarding the G5 and B4 pawns you're also
preventing Pawn to F4 so maybe here
waiting with Knight to C6 trying to just
maybe repeat uh would be the way to go
and also of course the Knight can never
be captured due to this check which
would just uh win material so Bishop to
C3 was played uh perhaps uh
unnecessarily and now Pawn to F4 this
allows Kik to advance forward a bit a
bit faster G captures King captures
Knight to F7 uh and now Rook to D5 and
this is uh one moment before Rook to D5
was made here in this position uh it's
still uh completely winning for uh for
cring but after Rook to D5 he allows
Anand this one slitter of Hope if he
manages to figure it out he did not find
it over the board but maybe you guys
will so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find the only move that
saves the game for Anand while I give
you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
realizing that once Rook d was played
the the E6 uh Square was no longer under
White's control and pawn to E6 now uh is
the only way for black knot to not to
lose this game so Pawn to E6 if played
uh there's no way to uh counter it Rook
to D7 okay you're attacking the pawn
once again but now King F6 comes and if
Rook to B7 uh what can you try Bishop to
D2 check you're going to chase the the
king back Bishop D1 check doesn't really
matter King F3 now even Knight to E5
check and after King to E2 Bishop to C3
and okay finally Rook to B6 will happen
there's no way to avoid losing this Pawn
but now King G5 and you you happily
trade Bishop captures uh Knight captures
and G4 and this is a draw even if you
trade here The Rook of course will not
be able to defeat the bishop and pawn as
this is unbreakable the only way to
break this is to actually capture the
bishop with the rook and then you'll get
a draw by insufficient material but
after Rook to D5 Anand did not play E6
Anand played Bishop back to B2 and now
uh Kik gains that one crucial Tempo King
to F5 guarding the E6 Square uh Bishop
to F6 and now Rook to
D1 now it's uh again uh it is winning
for white but you have to figure out a
way through Black's defenses and the
only way to do that is to take it little
by little and wait for black to weaken
his position so Knight to G5 now comes
Rook to D3 Knight back to F7 Rook to D7
uh Knight to D6 sorry not Knight to E5
Knight to D6 with check now comes King
to F4 uh getting the king out of way if
you go to E6 uh okay we said that if you
get to E6 it's going to be great but
then you allow the black king to come to
G5 and then once the G4 Pawn hangs
that's uh that's a draw so King back to
F4 played precisely by Kik Knight to F7
and now Rook back to B7 we have Bishop
to E5 check King to E3 and Bishop to D6
again the bishop on the dark dark
squares guards the pawns that are on the
dark squares King to E4 Knight to G5
with check King to F5 and now Bishop to
D5 uh sorry Knight to F3 first uh and
now Bishop to D5 putting pressure on the
Knight we have Knight to H4 with check
and King to G5 attacks the Knight Knight
to G6 and now Rook to A7 now the idea is
uh Rook to A1 Rook to F1 and Rook to F7
check if you can get that in of course
you are winning we have Knight to f wait
King to F5 now first uh Bishop to C5 and
now Bishop uh Rook back to B7 still
waiting with this um maneuver as you've
won U uh well a lot of scores even
without this maneuver and you want to
improve the position of your king and
pawn before going for that so the pawn
will advance further we have Bishop to
D6 Pawn to G5 now Knight back to G6 now
Rook back to A7 again with the same idea
of Rook to F1 to F7 Knight to f8 and now
now Bishop back to B3 we have Knight to
G6 uh Rook to A8 still playing a few
moves winning winning some time we have
King to G4 uh Bishop to C7 and now King
to H5 we have Bishop to D6 and now Rook
to C8 again you could uh REM maneuver
The Rook this way uh Bishop to E5 and
now Rook to C5 attacks the bishop Knight
to G6 defending and now Rook to C8 going
after Rook to G8 check so Knight to f8
and now Rook back to C1 we have Bishop
to C3 and finally Rook to F1 going after
Rook to F7 check we have Pawn to E6 um
uh the the pawn now finally advances uh
but that means it is no longer on a dark
square and only the knight and king can
defend it now you can't use your your
Bishop to just defend both of these
pawns Rook to D1 uh now comes King to F7
and Rook to d8 we have Knight back to G6
and now Rook to D7 with check King to E8
and now of course not moving The Rook
Bishop to A4 threatening all sorts of
nasty discoveries ban once again very
resourceful plays Knight to E5 just
attacks the rook and says there are no
good discoveries my knight is defended
by the bishop my Bishop is defended by
the pawn if you go after the pawn I'll
just defend it with my king So how do
you how do you make progress here uh
Rook to B7 with check uh asking the
black king where do you go now if you go
to the queen side then the pawn marches
forward but if you go to the king side
which was played in the game the pawn
again marches forward G6 we have Knight
to D3 uh and now King to H6 getting
ready for that P final Pawn push we have
Knight to C5 Anam being very tricky here
as the uh Bishop is undefended here and
now Rook to B8 with check King to E7 and
now uh Bishop back to C2 of course you
don't want to advance the pawn then the
bishop just captures it and the Knight
captures Bishop so Bishop to to C2 was
played we have Knight to D7 and now Rook
to B7 pinning the Knight here King to D6
unpinning and now Pawn to G7 and that's
it there's no more uh no no more tricks
to try here Bishop captures and G7 check
was played uh Kik recaptured and he was
in this position un move
101 that vatan Anan resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here so
a remarkable game where U the the an
employs the groomfield defense uh R goes
for that uh wild uh Pawn sacrifice and
then even a two- Pawn sacrifice for for
some activity and uh in the end he
manages to get out on top so if you
struggle with the groomfield you know
maybe maybe you can try this maybe it
works out well for you H but also if you
play the groomfield and you face this
with white you will have some ideas of
maybe how to uh how to approach it a
little bit better so yeah kaspar tried
the same line against kramnik like I
said in in um 1998 in Linares uh but
their game ended in a draw uh so these
These are the three victories that Kik
had in this do Manas Tournament of 1996
against Anand against Kasparov and the
previous one against V lean chuk so
three of the three of the biggest fish
in the pool uh and um due to this loss
Anand also like Kasparov finishes on
five and a half out of nine trailing
half a point behind wessing topalo and
Vladimir kramnik uh and yeah you resign
this of course you're down a full Rook
there's no point in playing this okay
you do have pawns but there's no way to
actually make something of the pawns I
mean this this Pawn falls on the next
move and uh that's pretty much it you
can't play King C5 or the Knight hangs
uh no no counterplay here uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
I will probably cover a few more games
from this tournament as it is a very
nice one we'll also check I don't think
I've ever checked out on any games
topalo played in this tournament and
even though Anand had five and a half
also the same as Kasparov Anand is the
only one who got four wins in this
tournament other you know got three at
the most uh so yeah once again really
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Welsh fan Wan Sasha vidler Mark
Henley Brennan and Michael males for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot really appreciate it as usual you
can check to of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the Chess World thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day